foreign
did you have a position on carbon
credits coming into the day yeah no the
position is no there must be something
important in carbon Market in other
words people have given up long time ago
so I guess I came in today thinking as a
tool carbon markets carbon credits can
be really valuable in creating the kind
of economic incentives we need today the
carbon markets have no Supply no demand
no transparency no regulation other than
that they're perfect you buy a carbon
offset from a forest but now the forest
is burned down or they were gonna chop
the tree down but they didn't and then
they did we know that we need carbon
removals to scale dramatically
different points of view can add to the
collective wisdom we'll work better if
we work together how do we generate
those connections that together move us
forward the concern that I've got about
Net Zero I'm probably going to discreet
about this right it might be taking away
some of the sense of urgency we can be
optimistic where we can be pessimistic
but the work looks the same is there
anything that struck you about carving
credits or carbon markets that you want
to talk about well I'll wait until the
session is over to give some considered
opinions on that
foreign
[Music]
throughout the world we find ourselves
faced with self-inflicted and
interconnected problems that challenge
our social fabric our Economic Security
and the variability of the earth to
sustain us
we're certainly not short on ideas to
address these problems but we often get
caught up in arguments against one
another vying for Supremacy instead of
deciding on a course of action
so how can we move forward it begins by
acknowledging the difference between
choices and dilemmas
some decisions come down to choice you
weigh the Alternatives decide and move
on
but often complex situations need both
and thinking instead of either all they
require us to hold competing values
together rather than make
straightforward choices we call these
dilemmas
I'm Lindsay Levin co-founder of Ted
countdown and this is why we launched
our dilemma series
to look at some of the thorniest issues
in the climate space and see how through
deep listening and collaboration we find
Pathways forward in our first dilemma
event we tackled the question is there a
role for carbon credits in accelerating
the transition to a fair Net Zero world
first let's start with some definitions
a carbon credit is a tradable permit
that usually represents one ton of
carbon either not emitted or removed
from the atmosphere
carbon offsetting is the practice of
buying carbon credits to compensate for
carbon emissions generated elsewhere
carbon markets are where carbon credits
are bought sold and priced Net Zero
refers to a theoretical state in which
overall human-produced carbon emissions
are equivalent to zero because any
ongoing emissions have been compensated
or offset by removals we're going to
take you on a journey
we'll explore why so many people have
lost faith in how carbon markets are Net
Zero targets operate in practice we'll
hear from people working in Frontline
communities to protect and restore
nature and Safeguard livelihoods and to
close we'll talk about Solutions
we hope this film will speak to those
working in sustainability and Beyond
whether you're directly able to
influence the supply or demand side of
carbon markets or you're just interested
in how we solve the climate crisis these
issues affect us all let's start by
hearing about some of the promises and
pitfalls in a conversation between Ted's
David bielo and Gilda fire of carbon
market watch
now carbon credits are being used as a
big tool to neutralize otherwise growing
emissions are they working
so my short answer to this uh would be
that they're not
um first because there is a major
concern around the actual quality of
those credits that each supposed to
represent a full ton of CO2 that's been
reduced or removed and permanently
stored but in reality many of those
credits actually don't represent that
full ton of CO2 in addition to that many
credits are used in inappropriate ways
by companies for example a company that
would make a net zero claim a carbon
neutrality claim for a specific product
but with these claims actually only
covering 10 or 20 or 50 percent of the
total emissions of that companies or of
the good and this ultimately is
misleading it's misleading to the public
it's misleading to Regulators it's
misleading to business partners it gives
the impression
that this com these companies this
product doesn't have a net negative
impact in the climate when in reality it
certainly does so what does it mean when
a company says it has neutralized uh the
emissions from its products or
activities well in most cases means a
company has purchased a certain number
of common credits but there is a lot of
unclarity around the actual quality of
those credits what do they represent as
well as the share of total emissions
that's really being covered that's
really being compensated through the
purchase of these credits and this issue
of clarity of transparency and so I
think that's really something that we
need to seriously address right now in
the current context of a booming Market
where there is a lot of interest a lot
of investment in growing it quantity
delivery quantitatively
if we don't address the quality
dimension of it we're going to grow a
system in which there's not going to be
any trust or that trust is progressively
going to erode and ultimately that will
destroy the value of the system itself
sounds like something called green
washing can you give us some
particularly egregious examples of of
that kind of activity
yeah I think you know carbon neutral
fossil fuels is an obvious one
that many of you will will certainly
have had heard of I mean to me it's just
it's an oxymoron it makes no sense it is
flawed conceptually and practically at a
conceptual level it gives the impression
that we can continue to burn fossil
fuels in the way we've been doing it for
decades exactly what has landed Us in
the crisis we are in today and that's
somehow magically we can do this without
having a net impact on the climate and
that is fundamentally misleading and
it's damaging it is harmful to our
Collective willingness to adopt the
behavioral changes and the costly
Investments that we need to adopt in
order to transition to a safer Planet
while we can agree that cutting
greenhouse gas emissions as soon as
possible is our ultimate goal the idea
of Net Zero has inspired some pretty
vigorous debate here's Professor James
Dyke of the University of Exeter with
his concerns
within just a few years netzera has
become the anchor concept for the
world's plans to avoid disaster it
sounds simple enough its Central premise
is that the risks of climate change is
that there is too much carbon dioxide in
the Earth's atmosphere so it follows we
must stop emitting more and even remove
some of it
hopefully by the middle of this Century
any residual emissions will be balanced
by technologies that remove carbon from
the atmosphere
but by introducing carbon removals Into
Climate policies we have set a trap
because it's incredibly seductive to
rely on carbon removals in the future
instead of Rapid decarbonization now it
gives the impression we are acting so
businesses don't need to change their
models and governments don't need to
propose bold action
what this means is that it is now almost
inevitable that we will be entering a
warmer and more dangerous world
how did this happen how did the idea of
net zero become so compromised so
corrupted
a key moment for the development of Net
Zero was the 2015 Paris agreement
the overall objective of this Landmark
climate treaty was that global warming
should be limited to no more than 1.5
degrees Celsius to reduce the risks of
devastating impacts many scientists
including myself were very skeptical
that this was possible given the absence
of radical proposals
but there was also a deep sense of
responsibility to try to make the Paris
agreement work
they soon discovered it was impossible
to get their models to decarbonize as
fast as 1.5 required if one assumed
continuous economic growth
the only way to make the models work was
by introducing carbon removal more
recently attention has turned to DAC
direct air capture this would strip out
carbon dioxide molecules directly from
the air and then pump them to
underground storage sites
the technology is interesting but
attempts to scale up DAC faced two
fundamental challenges first the process
is extremely energy intensive requiring
significant amounts of electricity and
sometimes natural gas to run
second safely storing carbon dioxide is
not a trivial Enterprise it's likely to
be the case that every carbon storage
site will need to be carefully tailored
to the specific geological circumstances
at the injection sites
now such concerns with carbon removal
are sometimes rushed away with a sheer
enthusiasm that surrounds these
Technologies the Assumption appears to
be that large-scale carbon removal will
work because it has to work
even if we assume these Technologies do
emerge at scale it's likely they will be
very expensive to run some studies
estimate many trillions of US dollars
to no evident economic benefit since
it's about clearing up carbon pollution
and hiding it underground the time has
come for us to voice our fears about Net
Zero policies and that begins by
leveling with the public about the Paris
agreement
at the moment we are desperately trying
to manage the narrative and adjusting
models in order to avoid acknowledging
that the Paris agreement is failing
a 2021 survey conducted by the science
journal Nature
found that the majority of ipcc climate
scientists who responded thought we were
heading towards a catastrophic three
degrees Celsius of warming
only four percent thought limiting to
1.5 was likely we can avoid climate
catastrophe
but I fear we won't if we don't confront
our wishful thinking around Net Zero as
you can see carbon markets are not
uniformly delivering what they promise
and many believe they may actually be
making things worse however they are
potentially a mechanism to provide
investment in vital natural solutions
and if done differently could bring
significant money to people and places
that need it here is Kavita prakesh Mani
of mondi nature to talk about ways to
ensure that local communities benefit
from this growing industry
let me start by saying that a ton of
carbon is not just a ton of carbon it
embodies in its natural protection
Community interests and benefits as well
as helping save us from disastrous
climate change
we have a lot of nature-based
conservation organizations protecting
and restoring our ecosystems and they're
all wondering how they can be part of
this carbon Market their ability to
monetize carbon that they sequester will
be crucial for their long-term survival
and the impact that we all want after
all nature and climate are two sides of
the same coin
however to get to those opportunities we
need to address some really systemic
challenges
take for example the technical aspects
that we have on any carbon credit
additionality permanence no leakage
baselining all very difficult concepts
for these small organizations add to
that measurement and verification
how do we get pre-feasibility studies
feasibility studies project development
how do these small organizations take on
these high costs when the price of
carbon is very low to deliver these
documentation
but that's not the problem with the
larger players and there's a systemic
imbalance of power larger ngos companies
project developers all have access to
International markets and institutional
Finance the smaller organizations see
the opportunity but just do not have the
means to tap into it we should also look
one level higher at governments take for
instance Indonesia
a country with the highest potential of
carbon mitigation from nature-based
Solutions it's the third largest
tropical forest it has a coastline with
mangroves and it has 15 to 30 million
hectares of beetland
but the government has restricted any
new projects from being developed or
carbon credits from being sold to the
international market
this has Merit because after all
developing countries also need to meet
the nationally determined contributions
and they do not have to sell cheap
credits to developed countries that have
already destroyed part of the
environment or companies that are not
decarbonizing
however it does restrict international
finance from going into conservation and
into communities
some countries are trying to get the
market to work in Asia that's Vietnam
and Cambodia but we still do not have
the right Market mechanisms to ensure
that it's Equitable safe and the impact
that we want as Kavita said a ton of
carbon is not just a ton of carbon to
build on that here's Susan chamba of the
World Resources Institute Africa to talk
in more detail about all the things we
miss when we think too narrowly about
carbon benefits and nothing else
so I'm going to talk to you about
all the elements about carbon markets
that have got nothing to do with carbon
our forest
piglands and oceans
are more than the carbon that they store
they're the foundation
of livelihoods of billions of people
who depend on them directly and
indirectly
they provide the hydrological functions
that ensure we have Rivers
we have legs and that we can grow food
successfully
they are home to biodiversity
they're also home to indigenous people
who protect them with their blood
Sweat and Tears
so when we lose these ecosystems the
livelihoods of local communities and
Indigenous people are adversely affected
when you look at the way we design the
carbon markets
we designed them with various
assumptions first of all
carbon markets perpetuate the notion
that our forests and peatlands are all
about carbon
they Overlook the ecosystem services
that these ecosystems provide
such as clean water
healthy and nutritious food
biodiversity and its related services
such as pollination
Pest Control
and even nitrogen fixation
companies are prepared to pay for carbon
because it helps them to tick either
their compliance box or the Public
Relation boxes
but rarely do we couple that with the
other ecosystem services that these
natural ecosystems are providing carbon
markets perpetuate the notion that we
can continue with our fossil fuel driven
Lifestyles and offset our externalities
and perhaps even our guilt on the poor
local communities that are located in
the global South in fact nowadays
if a lot of projects provide a lot of
ecosystem services but are not solid on
the carbon side they are often dismissed
as
poorly designed or poorly governed
carbon markets are based on complicated
and costly reporting and verification
systems
and these end up taking up most of the
revenue that is then coming from carbon
and local communities get the leftovers
if they are lucky
the value and the price of carbon
compared to Alternative land uses such
as mining fossil fuel extraction
has been far too low for far too long
and so what we are witnessing is
governments in the global South continue
to issue permits for mining
for exp for oil exploration
in some of the most critical ecosystems
peatlands forests I work a lot in the
Congo Basin I see it every day
so we've heard what isn't working a more
existing carbon markets often miss on
the ground now let's dive into different
ways of thinking that could reshape the
system and actually generate the
positive outcomes we want here's Gabriel
Walker of rethinking removals
I think the carbon Market is immensely
powerful
and immensely valuable and I do think we
can use it as a powerful tool for
helping to solve the climate crisis
but I've also started to think that
we've been thinking about it the wrong
way there are three really big and
important climate outcomes that the
carbon Market could help with so there's
reducing fossil emissions as fast as
possible
there's protecting natural carbon sinks
and there's removing CO2 from the
atmosphere reduction protection and
removal
and I found that in lots of people's
minds those three get kind of smooshed
together in one generic kind of offset
but it's worth separating them out
because those outcomes need different
kinds of incentives
so I'll show you what I mean if you
start with the first one reducing fossil
emissions as fast as possible that's
reduction credits
now one problem with those is that they
don't actually neutralize emissions so
if I put a ton of CO2 in the air
and I pay you not to put your ton of CO2
in the air my tan is still there it
doesn't get you to zero it doesn't
neutralize and this is a realm of quite
a lot of traditional assets another
issue with them is they tend to be very
cheap
less than twenty dollars a ton so it can
get immensely tempting just to buy loads
of credits and not do the hard work of
reducing your own emissions
and that is not where we should be
putting the money
but where reduction credits can help us
in creating clean infrastructure in
places where it wouldn't have happened
otherwise
so if you think about it that way that's
the outcome you're trying to get to then
the incentives to build around reduction
credits the highest rated reduction
credits will be the ones that drive
money towards building clean
infrastructure in the global South
and the cheapest coal-fired power plant
to shut down
will be the one in the global South that
was never built in the first place
okay so that's the first one second one
a protecting natural carbon sinks
now like uh these already exist in the
carbon market like the uh reduction
credits and light reduction credits they
don't neutralize emissions I put a ton
of CO2 in the air you stop a tongue
coming out from a sink my tongue's still
in the air
um they also tend to get smooshed
together there isn't a separate category
called protection credits yet
and I think it's worth separating them
out because it's hugely important to
drive money towards protecting those
things
rainforests at peatlands so then what
incentives you build around what are the
highest rated protection credits they'd
be the ones maybe with the with the
biggest carbon stores
maybe the ones that are most vulnerable
maybe the ones that protect the most
biodiversity maybe the ones that drive
the money towards the communities that
are actually their husbanding and
protecting those stores
okay third category we've heard a lot
about this third category removal
credits that's taking a ton of CR to the
atmosphere and keeping it out
so unlike the other two categories of
credit removals credits really do
neutralize emissions if I would have
turn the CO2 in the air I pay you to
remove a ton you get to zero because
what goes up does come down
those are the only category of credits
that can be used to claim Net Zero none
of the others can do it
they do already exist in the carbon
Market a really tiny percentage of the
total
and we're going to need an awful lot
more of them
so at the moment every year we're
removing durably maybe a hundred
thousand tons of CO2
and according to the ipcc carbon
removals are now unavoidable to get to
Net Zero by 2050 and by 2050 we're going
to have to be removing billions of tons
so to get from a hundred thousand tons
to billions of tons
we're gonna have to start really small
and this almost non-existent industry
and scale it up to the gigaton scale
affordably without causing other
undesirable side effects and making sure
that these removals are real
and we've got to get the cost down very
quickly the way that we did for solar
and wind so that's the objective that's
the outcome that we're trying to achieve
so that's a way to reorganize our
overall thinking around carbon credits
but how should companies reshape their
thinking here is Derek brokoff of the
Stockholm environment Institute
Net Zero has become the dominant
Paradigm for a climate ambition
many countries have announced Net Zero
targets and so many companies are doing
the same
today I want to challenge the idea that
companies should emphasize achieving Net
Zero for themselves rather than focus on
how best to contribute to Global Net
Zero
I like the way carbon 4 frames it quote
a company is not carbon neutral it
contributes to neutrality
let me explain why I believe it's
essential to make this distinction
current net zero Frameworks presume that
companies should imitate at a corporate
level what must happen globally that is
reduce their own emissions as far as
possible and balance out the emissions
that remain with carbon dioxide removals
yet this notion is already leading to a
perverse effect on how companies spend
their mitigation dollars according to at
least one study just a handful of
companies have already pledged more
removals than the entire world could
provide
at a global level removing carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere will be
essential for limiting global warming as
the ipcc for example has made abundantly
clear
but having corporate actors purchase
removals in bulk to achieve their own
mini versions of Net Zero misses the
forest for the trees
the world desperately needs to reduce
emissions
to move the world towards net zero
companies would do better in the near
term to both reduce their own emissions
and help others do the same first focus
on the big picture
the idea of achieving Net Zero at a
corporate level is self-centered
we need to change the narrative from
we're no longer part of the problem if
we've neutralized our emissions two we
are part of a global solution to climate
change
this means not just imitating what needs
to happen globally but instead taking
actions that beneficially Advance a
global net zero outcome including by
prioritizing emission reductions over
removals in the near term
second
put Equity front and center
from a scientific perspective there's no
reason why the correct level of
emissions for any given actor should be
Net Zero
what is fair and feasible could be net
positive zero or negative emissions
companies should focus on making
Equitable contributions to Global goals
including through near-term support for
emission reductions outside their value
chains
third connect with larger policy efforts
no company acting on its own can solve
the climate crisis
we urgently need to focus attention on
Collective action
companies that are truly committed to
Net Zero need to support climate
policies at all levels of government and
internationally that advance and
Equitable comprehensive and coordinated
Global transitions we know many people
think carbon credits and the idea of Net
Zero are deeply flawed but do they have
to be
in our next talk Annette Nazareth of the
Integrity Council for voluntary carbon
markets lays out a set of required core
principles to build a market that
delivers robust quantifiable and climate
positive outcomes
our starting point for the voluntary
carbon Market
is that it exists to accelerate a just
transition to 1.5 degrees
it is an important complementary tool to
mobilize billions of dollars that
wouldn't otherwise be available Into
Climate mitigation that wouldn't
otherwise happen
but it will only deliver on that promise
if it is rooted in high integrity
an important thing to know about the
voluntary carbon markets is that it is
as its name suggests voluntary
it's driven by private sector actors and
it's not regulated by governments or by
Financial authorities
but unregulated cannot mean chaotic or
opaque
I spent much of my career as a markets
regulator and I know markets
and I know that there are some who think
that markets are always looking for some
new product to Hawk and today that
product is carbon
that's why in designing an effective
Market we have to start with Integrity
these core carbon principles which we
call ccps will address the most critical
elements of credit quality
they include additionality
permanence
robust quantification
validation and verification
no double Counting
transition to net zero emissions
and sustainable development impacts and
safeguards
so let me unpack those a bit
additionality
additionality means that the emission
reduction or emission wouldn't have
happened
without the revenue from carbon credits
permanence means that those reductions
and removals will stand the test of time
and if they don't they will be fully
compensated
an example of that would be a forestry
project that issues carbon credits that
is then destroyed in a wildfire
robust quantification means that the
impact of the credits is accurately
measured and accounted for
conservatively based on solid science
validation and verification means that
the numbers are genuine and meaningful
and are validated and verified by an
accredited body that has the Integrity
to do that job robustly
no double counting means that a carbon
credit is registered and issued only
once and the emissions reductions and
removals that that credit generates will
only be claimed by one party
meanwhile
our colleagues at the voluntary carbon
markets Integrity initiative the vcmi
are working on similar standards that
will address credible claims so that we
can come to a common understanding that
carbon credits will only count
if they are used as a complementary tool
within a legitimate Net Zero pathway if
we have integrity
in the supply of credits
how they are traded and how they are
used then a powerful price signal will
emerge The Dilemma series was born out
of a strong conviction that when
reasonable people disagree the way out
is not to dismiss one side over another
but in fact to hold and value different
points of view and see what we can
generate together
in dilemma thinking this is called the
resolution Zone and reaching it is vital
if we're going to make real progress on
climate
let's hear again from some leading
voices who we invited to share ideas ask
questions and engage in productive
debate in my inbox every day are the
debates in the climate Community about
how exactly we're going to get this done
and the debates are important because
this is the hardest problem that we've
ever faced and so we have to have open
ears even more open perhaps to our
critics than to the ones who agree with
us because we have so much to figure out
add a good conversation about how as
much as I would like to Pretend We're
going to get there on climate because of
trust and relationships we've wasted all
the time for that so we really need to
get there by alignment if we can agree
to a few things that Lee did not dire on
a fiery gas ball I will build my
relationships on the way to that
we heard in the first sessions about how
to make sure that the carbon Market is
working for people on the ground and
communities on the ground who didn't do
anything to contribute to climate change
are going to be often the most
vulnerable to bearing the brunt of its
impacts they're not thinking about the
carb Market we heard that from Susan
chamba from her work in Burundi we heard
that from Kavita prakashmani from her
work with smallholders in Southeast Asia
the thing that shifted my thinking the
most was the way that Annette Nazareth
talked about what is necessary to create
in an integrated and high integrity
carbon Market that level of clarity I
found actually shifted my mind in terms
of structuring a market in a valuable
way there were a lot of kind of
overlapping ideas on how to get to
solutions from people who don't really
agree on everything all carbon removal
proposals need to be based on robust
science engineering and economics
once we have a credible total amount of
carbon that can be removed by proposed
technology that includes its capture and
safe storage then and only then can it
be included in Net Zero policies and
models so to get from a hundred thousand
tons to billions of tons
we're going to have to start really
small and this almost non-existent
industry and scales up to the gigaton
scale affordably without causing other
undesirable side effects and making sure
that these removals are real on the
government side we need clear guidance
and clear regulation good carbon markets
must help us to cut emissions from The
Source we have to decarbonize our supply
chains we have to decarbonize our
economies we have to decarbonize our
lifestyles
I think deep listening really matters
for conversations like the ones we had
today and the ongoing thorniness of
people who feel threatened by a planet
in Decline trying to make decisions the
heterodoxy of perspective and opinion
stimulates new ideas and if you start
the conversations with respect and with
open minds you get to new places and we
had that in our breakout group for sure
but
we need a kind of grounded sense of of
Hope and optimism which has got kind of
rough edges and realism I agree and we
somehow need to embrace yeah those fears
because often we don't want to right so
I think that a stubborn and determined
optimism lies on the other side of
Despair I think you have to go through
that and you have to stare into the
abyss and say this is possible it may
even be likely but you know what I'm
going to do everything I can at this
moment to be the change to create that
difference I've never heard so many
polite people disagree about things they
hate I've never met so many people who
hate offsets who are still super nice
and trying to figure out what could be
useful about a thing they're not sold on
it is useful to be reminded to to like
be patient to listen to learn to be open
to be warm to be generous and kind to
people who are on my side that I
disagree with sometimes we do need to
take a step back and not put all that
pressure on our own shoulders that we're
gonna find the solution but it's how do
we generate those connections that
together move us forward and maybe one
day I will be sadder and I will be less
optimistic but someone else will bring
that hope to me
when we try to reason collectively it's
really important and valuable to
recognize that different points of view
can add to the collective wisdom one of
the most powerful telescopes in the
world had an Innovative design when it
was built including the decision to
build two virtually identical telescopes
only 60 meters apart if they're looking
at a supernova 100 million light years
away
uh it turns out that the ability to view
that object from two different points of
view only 60 meters apart on a small
planet makes all the difference in the
amount of information that can be
collected and processed and used to
enhance our understanding and the same
thing is true when we try to reason
together in a group if there are
different points of view then the
different life experiences of everyone
in the group can add to the collective
wisdom and make the group far smarter
than the smartest individual in that
group
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign